to kick off the ASEAN summit the FIFA
president handed out these customized
football shirts to the leaders of the
ten member Association of Southeast
Asian Nations the bloc focuses on
regional unity while embracing each
nations individual culture but much of
the focus recently has been on how
nations outside are impacting ASEAN
Chinese Premier Li Keqiang spoke to the
group's leaders several ASEAN nations
have territorial disputes with China and
he welcomed progress in negotiations for
a code of conduct in the South China Sea
Beijing has been accused of delaying
those talks for years while it built
Islands undisputed reefs in waterways
critical to shipping and thought to have
huge oil reserves underneath Indian
Prime Minister Narendra Modi also met
the leaders he did not mention the
ongoing negotiations between 16
countries on a regional free trade deal
known as our SEP there are reports that
India has raised some concerns but some
think a deal is not far off but won't be
agreed during this summit the fact is
that the region needs this deal the
symbolism of this deal would be enormous
it would become the world's largest
trading bloc half of the world's
population 40% of the global economy and
this region is also going to become the
center of gravity of global trade and
that's something that would be good news
for some ASEAN nations that have been
hurting under pressure from the ongoing
us-china trade war the u.s. downgraded
its representation here at the ASEAN
summit compared to previous years
sending the Commerce Secretary as the
highest-ranking member of the American
delegation some see this as not only as
an indication of the importance the
Trump administration places on this
region but also as an opportunity for
China when all the leaders of the
asia-pacific you know they asked in
related summits when they show up
without the US president counterpart is
going to undermine US interest and also
the interest of the other countries in
the region that are looking for a kind
of a counterbalance to China
so the unity within ASEAN might become
more important than ever as nations
outside the region jostle for influence
Scott Heidler al Jazeera Bangkok